ja meine damen und den das armband aus
dem auf das robert-koch-institut
präsident lothar wieler jetzt in der
vorbereitung wir haben jetzt einen fall
in sachsen anhalt wird das gleich
bestätigen punkt 10 uhr wird er jetzt
die pressekonferenz eröffnen
das ist er entscheidend neue stand das
lka heute update wie zum 10
für ihre fragen zur verfügung stehen der
präsident des robert koch instituts und
wie immer gibt es zunächst einen
überblick über die aktuelle situation
danach haben sie die gelegenheit fragen
zu stellen und vielleicht schaffen wir
dann im anschluss noch einsammeln
statement im foyer jetzt schon die
ankündigung das nächste pressebriefing
findet morgen zur gleichen uhrzeit hier
statt
es sei denn sie hören noch was anderes
von uns ja guten tag zusammen gut im
hörsaal ihr die anwesenden und auch
natürlich die zuschauer außerhalb
zunächst noch mal eine kleine
lage-einschätzung wie wir das jeden tag
durchführen jeden werktag zumindest hier
wie sieht die lage in der welt aus wie
sieht die situation in anderen staaten
aus innerhalb chinas außerhalb chinas
wir unterscheiden nach wie vor zwischen
china und anderen ländern
wie lange wir das noch machen werden
werden wir sehen
wir haben zurzeit heute morgen 8 uhr
folgende zahlen 111.000 zahlen 111.000
meldungen insgesamt 3879 sterbefälle
das ist eine rate von 3,5 prozent eine
sterberate in china gestaltet sich die
zahlen so dass wir dort 80 1860 fälle
haben von denen 3121 verstorben sind
das wäre in china entsprechend einer
sterberate von 3,9 prozent
wir nehmen außerhalb chinas eine
deutlich dynamischere zu zuwachs von
zahlen nehmen wir wahr
das heißt die meldungen die außerhalb
chinas kommen im vergleich zu den
innerhalb chinas nehmen immer weiter zu
wir haben außerhalb chinas nun 29.000
154 fälle
hierunter sind 707 menschen
verstorben an der krankheit das ist
außerhalb chinas eine sterberate von 2,5
prozent in der region euro die ich immer
noch mal etwas näher betrachtet
12.300 33 fälle 411 todesfälle
sterberate wäre dort 3,6 prozent möchte
noch mal wiederholen dass das alles die
meldezahlen sind die meldezahlen geben
immer einen momentanen einblick in eine
epidemiologische situation in jedem land
wird zu verschiedenen zeiten in denen in
diese epidemie jeweils hineingeschaut
oder in das ausbruchsgeschehen in jedem
land beruhen die meldezahlen auf
meldungen
teilweise sind die fall definition
unterschiedlich die wichtigste
mitteilung ist einfach zum verständnis
für alle weltweit nehmen die fälle zu
die dynamik ist groß und weltweit nehmen
die fälle zu und die zahl der länder die
betroffen sind nehmen ebenfalls zu
lassen sie mich nun ein paar worte sagen
zu deutschland
in deutschland haben wir mit dem stand
heute 1139 laborbestätigte fälle und der
schwerpunkt der fälle liegt nach wie vor
in nordrhein-westfalen doch sind es 400
84 fälle in baden württemberg 204 fälle
und in bayern 2 156 fälle die anderen
verteilen sich wir haben gestern die
risikobewertung für deutschland
angepasst und das ist wichtig noch
einmal zum verständnis wir haben das
zwar mehrfach erläutert aber ich glaube
es ist immer wieder wichtig
festzustellen dass wir eine
systematische vorgehensweise haben bei
der risikobewertung von anderen ländern
oder unserem eigenen land und anhand
dieser risikobewertung das tun wir vor
allen dingen deshalb damit ärzte wissen
wie sie mit möglichen patienten umgehen
sollen das sind epidemiologische
informationen um ganz gezielt einen
patienten vielleicht testen zu lassen
oder nicht
und darum haben wir eine ganz
systematisch
vorgehensweise im robert-koch-institut
etabliert das ist übrigens auch der
grund warum wir so früh schon fälle
diagnostiziert haben bevor wir große
fälle haben viele schwer verlaufende
fälle das heißt wir haben den anfang
dieses aufbruchs und der beginn der
epidemie sehr früh erkannt
wir haben gestern die risikoeinschätzung
folgendermaßen geändert die gefährdung
für die gesundheit der bevölkerung in
deutschland wird derzeit insgesamt als
mäßig eingeschätzt
diese gefährdung variiert aber von
region zu region und es ist in besonders
betroffenen gebieten ist die gefährdung
natürlich höher als in anderen gebieten
das ist der grund warum wir gebiete
unterschiedlich einschätzen
die wahrscheinlichkeit für schwere
krankheitsverläufe nimmt mit zunehmendem
alter und bestehenden vorerkrankungen zu
das wissen sie auch weil das seit vielen
wochen bereits so vermeldet wird und
weil das überall auf der welt auch so
ist und das ist in deutschland natürlich
genauso
die belastung des gesundheitswesens
hängt maßgeblich von der regionalen
verbreitung der infektion den
vorhandenen kapazitäten und den
eingeleiteten gegenmaßnahmen ab
isolierung quarantäne soziale
distanzierung und sie kann örtlich sehr
hoch sind diese einschätzung kann sich
kurzfristig durch neue erkenntnisse
ändern und das ist einer unserer
kernaufgaben diese neuen erkenntnisse
auszuwerten zu analysieren und darauf
beruhend eben unsere lage anzupassen das
heißt die situation ist eben nicht über
ganz deutschland gleich sondern es gibt
ein besonders gefährdetes gebiet
momentan das ist der kreis heinsberg
und doch ist die gefährdung natürlich
größer wir werden zudem heute die
risikoeinschätzung für das land italien
ändern
mit dem heutigen tag wenn wir ganz
italien zu einem risikogebiet erklären
und das sind die wesentlichen
informationen für den moment ich möchte
nochmals zusammenfassen so wie ich das
auch wirklich schon seit vielen tagen
und seitdem wir das pressebriefing
abhalten
sagen es ist eine ernste situation
ich fordere alle bürgermeister und
landräte auf ihre krisenpläne zu
aktivieren
ich fordere alle ärzte ärztinnen alle
hospitäler auf ihre krisenpläne zu
aktivieren
die krankenhäuser müssen sich darauf
vorbereiten wenn sie mehr schwere fälle
haben dass sie die entsprechenden
strukturen in ihren krankenhäusern
anpassen und das ist wichtig wir stehen
aber anfang dieser epidemie
wir werden sie nur bewältigen wenn alle
verantwortungsträger in unserem land mit
dieser bevorstehenden krise entsprechend
umgehen
danke gibt es fragen hierzu hatten sie
bitte auf das mikrofon von petersdorff
tagesschau das thema mortalität wenn ich
ich kann mich noch erinnern anzahl von
03 05 das kann man ja angesichts der
zahlen die sie jetzt gesagt haben
vergessen eigentlich nein nummer es ist
wirklich schwer zu verstehen und dass
ich kann das auch nachvollziehen
in der leyen presse werden natürlich die
begrifflichkeiten ständig vermischt
manche sprechen von letalität manchmal
mortalität manche von sterberaten die
letalität also wirklich die zahl
derjenigen die infiziert wurde und
gestorben ist werden wir natürlich erst
nach der epidemie wirklich kennen das
sind immer meldezahlen nur die meldezahl
end geben immer nur ein teil der
wahrheit wider
es wird immer mehr infizierte menschen
geben als gemeldet werden das ist
überhaupt nicht machbar das alle zahlen
gemeldet wenn das heißt also wir sehen
immer nur momentane zahlen die einen
momentanen status wiedergeben der uns
aber da wir erfahrene epidemiologen sind
und seit jahrzehnten natürlich die mit
abstand kompetentes der einrichtung in
deutschland ist die sich jedes jahr mit
500.000 melde fällen in
deutschland auseinandersetzt mit allen
möglichen krankheiten haben jedes jahr
mehr als 20.000 ausbrüche mit allen
möglichen funktionen können wir können
sehr sehr gut einschätzen was diese
zahlen bedeuten
das heißt was wir zurzeit die zahlen die
ich ihnen vorgelesen habe sind sehr hohe
zahlen aber nehmen wir zb italien wo wir
schon sehr sehr viele verstorben haben
dort wurde der ausbruch sehr spät
erkannt und zwar anhand von toten
das heißt also dort ist natürlich der
das verhältnis von verstorbenen
mitmenschen zu denen die infiziert sind
extrem schlecht zur zeit das heißt also
sind sehr viele verstorben im vergleich
zu den wirklich infizierten und das sind
raten die sich alle anpassen werden es
wird natürlich weniger sein wie viel am
ende wie hoch das sein wird werden wir
nicht wissen wir nicht können wir nicht
sagen
aber entscheidend ist wir müssen die so
genannte variable gruppe in unseren
gesellschaft schützen das sind die alten
und hochaltrigen menschen vor allem
natürlich mit grunderkrankungen und das
sind auch menschen andere menschen
unabhängig vom alter die bestimmte
grunderkrankung am chronisch kranke im
und effiziente die müssen wir schützen
weil wir wissen dass bei ihnen die
krankheit eben einen schweren verlauf
nehmen kann
unabhängig davon wissen wir und das sind
zahlen die wir aus der ganzen welt haben
und die sich immer mehr bestätigen mehr
als 80 prozent werden eben nur milde
verläufe haben vier von fünf infizierten
auf der welt egal in welchem land werden
eine milde erkrankung durch leben und
nach wenigen wochen gesund ihrer wege
gehen ja um das noch mal sehr deutlich
zu sagen also vier von fünf werden eine
milde erkrankungen haben die infiziert
sind viele werden vielleicht auch kaum
ein erkrankung fast symptomfrei sein
aber es wird eben schwere fälle geben
und wir wissen die schweren fälle werden
vor allen dingen natürlich bei den
hochalpen und alten hochaltrigen und
alten menschen mit grunderkrankungen und
bei allen anderen die grunderkrankung
haben auftreten das ist die gruppe von
menschen die wir besonders schützen
müssen und das sagen wir seit wochen das
weiß auch jeder
und ich betone das gern nochmal und
deshalb möchte ich auch dass sie alle
die diese zahlen immer im internet
kursieren ja alle sind ja auch alle
richtig aber diese zahlen geben
natürlich nicht da die wahrheit wider
sondern es sind ja nur die fälle die
gemeldet sind weil sie eine meldesystem
zur verfügung gestellt werden und mit
dem können die profis berechnen was das
bedeutet aber die zahlen dürfen sie nur
als momentaufnahmen sehen und das ist
ein wichtiges verständnis was wir auch
in der pressekonferenz gestern ja in der
bundespressekonferenz nochmal klar
gemacht haben was wir immer wieder klar
machen
weitere fragen
dankeschön
die wortmann slowakische rundfunk hinter
zwei fragen erstere ob weiß man ungefähr
wie viele haben sich geheilt aus diesen
großen saal uns weiter was denken sie
was war wie hauptgrund verbreitung in
italien sagte haupt haupt diese kerle
und was was könnte die hauptkunden sein
dass verladung norditalien betroffen ist
also zur ersten frage
wir wissen dass mehr als 50.000 menschen
als geheilt entlassen wurden aber auch
das sind eben auch die zahlen die ich
ihnen sage wir gehen davon aus dass
natürlich mehr menschen sind denn das
sind ja auch alles prozesse viele der
schwer kranken werden ja teilweise
wochenlang behandelt und sind dann nach
dieser langen behandlung vielleicht
gehört das heißt da gibt es in verzug
von zahlen das kann ich ihnen nicht
sagen aber ich sage noch mal etwa vier
von fünf von denen wirklich infizierten
werden diese krankheit ohne größere
probleme überstehen was in italien dazu
geführt hat dass die zahlen sind das
kann ich ihnen nicht sagen ich weiß den
eintrag nicht da muss man die ruhe
lokalen behörden natürlich fahren das
heißt die information die wären ja vor
ort durchgeführt dort werden
untersuchungen durchgeführt
was die einen tag welle war dort werden
die patienten entsprechend behandelt das
wäre reine spekulation von meiner seite
aus dass dazu kann ich ihnen wirklich
keine fundierten auskünfte geben
dann hinten bitte ja groß 100 dpa herr
wieder ich habe auch zwei fragen
du bist du zum einen gerne wann geht ein
toter genau in die statistik ein also
als corona virus toter und die andere
frage ist haben eben gesagt die
krankenhäuser müssen strukturen
vorbereiten da würde ich sie bitten das
ich das nochmal genauer erklären was was
meinen sie mit strukturen und wie gut
können die krankenhäuser das im moment
auch gerade noch also gerade sind
hinblick auf beatmungsgeräte den sieg
beten
wie sehen da die kapazitäten noch aus ja
also der erste fall ist klar ist kann
natürlich nur einer als corona virus
patient verstorben gemeldet werden wenn
er als crooner virus infizierter
nachgewiesen wurde
das heißt er hatte die fall definition
ein crooner virus wurde bei ihm
bestätigt und dann ist er an dieser
viruskrankheit gestorben
das ist eine definitionssache ganz klar
die zweite frage ist im prinzip auch
sehr einfach zu beantworten also stellen
die ich zum beispiel vor wir haben das
ja auch schon seit längerem gesagt und
alle krankenhäuser haben wir solche
pläne es gibt ja pandemiepläne was heißt
dass ein pandemieplan
das heißt ein krankenhaus hat eine
bestimmte anzahl von betten und ein
krankenhaus hat eine bestimmte anzahl
von intensivbetten und eine bestimmte
anzahl von zum beispiel beatmungsgeräten
und man kann natürlich jetzt zum einen
bestimmte eingriffe die wirklich nicht
zwingend erforderlich sind einfach
aussetzen das ist der erste punkt dass
man also mehr krankenbetten nutzen kann
für menschen die schwer erkrankt sind
das ist der erste aspekt ich glaube das
ist eine sehr leichte überleben das kann
jeder mensch sofort nachzuvollziehen der
zweite aspekt ist der dass man wenn es
geht natürlich noch mehr intensivbetten
aufrüsten kann dass man zum beispiel die
beatmungsgeräte dass man es schafft die
kapazität zu erhöhen von ge ordnungs
geräten der dritte aspekt ist folgender
das personal im krankenhaus und das
ganze personal das medizinische
fachpersonal das wird natürlich in den
nächsten tagen und wochen sehr sehr viel
arbeit bekommen und man muss natürlich
aufpassen dass sich die person auch
nicht anstecken weil sie sonst als
behandler ausfallen
das heißt also ein krankenhaus kann
jetzt auch schon dafür sorge tragen dass
bestimmte patienten also ich sag mal
ganz normal patienten die fieber haben
die infekte haben die atemwegsinfekte
haben dass diese patienten anders in das
in das krankenhaus aufgenommen werden
als der rest der patienten also dass man
ein bestimmtes personal zum beispiel zur
verfügung stellt die sich ausschließlich
um diese patienten kümmert die dann
besonders die schützen das personal zum
beispiel also das sind glaube ich alles
maßnahmen wenn jeder der jetzt zuhört
oder jeder der hier im raum ist man in
ruhe drüber nachdenkt wie kann ein
krankenhaus sich darauf vorbereiten im
umgang mit diesen in diesen patienten
die kommen werden in der zukunft dann
gibt es eine vielzahl von möglichkeiten
wie er das macht und wenn es um den
aspekt schutzkleidung geht dann ist
natürlich sinnvoller wenn nicht sagen
wir jetzt mal in einer schicht eben
ständig die ärzte durch wechseln sondern
ein bestimmter anteil von ärzten und
medizinischem fachpersonal sich
ausschließlich sollten patienten kümmert
damit das risiko der ansteckung für
andere ärzte reduziert wurde es gibt
viele logistische maßnahmen die einfach
zu überlegen sind die durchgeführt
werden können und ich fordere intensiv
nun seid wirklich wochen seitdem wir das
briefing machen alle letzte und alle
hospitäler sich auf so eine situation
vorzubereiten gibt es weitere fragen
hallo hall christen von sky ja die
thematik hält auch die fußball
bundesliga in atem
geisterspiele werden diskutiert oder
auch das komplette aussetzen von
spieltagen was aus ist aus ihrer sicht
notwendig oder was ist ihre empfehlung
in dieser hinsicht also ein aspekt der
eine ganz große rolle spielt den wir
auch aus meiner sicht wirklich immer
wieder und sehr intensiv auch
kommunizieren
das geschehen muss ja verlangsamt werden
warum wollen wir das geschehen
verlangsamen
das ist unsere strategie seit anfang
januar wir wollen es verlangsamen damit
möglichst die anzahl der patienten die
schwere erkrankungen haben sich über
einen längeren zeitraum verteilen damit
das gesundheitssystem
besser damit zurecht kommt das können
sich vorstellen glaube ich jeder von
ihnen versteht dass wir nicht eine kurve
habe je spitzer die kurve ist desto mehr
patienten werden zur selben zeit
auftreten je flacher die kurve ist desto
mehr wird sich der zeitraum dahin
strecken wo die patienten dann
behandlung suchen und verlangsamen ist
natürlich das einfachste dadurch dass
man dafür sorge trägt dass menschen sich
nicht so schnell anstecken und wenn
viele menschen zusammen in einem engen
raum sind dann glaube ich ist auch jedem
sofort klar dass die chance dass wenn
einer von den menschen infiziert ist das
andere angesteckt werden größer als wenn
sie sich eben weiter voneinander
entfernen
in so viel gibt es überhaupt keine frage
dass wir natürlich alles dafür tun
sollten das veranstaltung die nicht
zwingend notwendig sind dass wir diese
veranstaltung entweder absagen oder eben
meiden
und hier muss man das auch noch mal ganz
deutlich sagen es gibt natürlich
bestimmte dinge das öffentliche leben
keiner nicht eingestellt werden es gibt
bestimmte dinge die müssen sein
ja wir brauchen eine versorgung wir
brauchen bestimmte dinge muss und das
ist klar da gibt es eine daseinsvorsorge
mit der versorgung mit ärzten patienten
lebensmitteln transportverkehr aber es
gibt einfach dinge auf die man auch
verzichten kann und aus meiner sicht
kann man eben auch verzichten
zu einem fußballspiel zu gehen und man
kann ein fußballspiel natürlich trotzdem
stattfinden lassen
aber wenn man dadurch die chance
reduziert dass sich menschen anstecken
dann ist dieses schutzgut aus meiner
sicht ein deutlich höheres als wenn man
als zuschauer in einem fußballstadion
sitzt ja das heißt also die ganze
strategie muss sein diese epidemie zu
verlangsamen und ich denke da kann jeder
sich gedanken machen wie er dazu
beiträgt durch so ein eigenes soziales
verhalten wie er dazu beiträgt dass das
geschieht
warten sie bitte auf das mikrofon dass
die zuschauer sie verstehen danke weil
sie sagten sie würden es geradezu
gebetsmühlenartig wiederholen dass sich
die krankenhäuser einstellen können sind
sie der meinung dass das nicht genügend
geschieht reagieren die krankenhäuser
und womöglich auch die ämter zu langsam
das ist die erste frage das zweite ist
was können sie ungefähr sagen mit was
für einer dunkelziffer sie der rechnen
wer noch an krone erkrankt dessen von
denen man gar nicht weiß weil wenn die
letalität eigentlich viel niedriger ist
muss man ja davon ausgehen dass viel
mehr menschen es haben ja also ich habe
nicht den eindruck dass das der fall ist
aber trotzdem erinnere ich natürlich
kontinuierlich das ist meine aufgabe das
ist die aufgabe unseres hauses und das
werden wir auch weiterhin tun
die zweite frage der dunkelziffer ist
nicht so einfach zu beantworten wir dass
das kommt sehr stark auf das jeweilige
land an wie intensiv getestet wurde
was ein test zur verfügung gestellt
wurde und wie strategisch man das angeht
ich möchte jetzt noch für unser land
sprechen wir haben ja schon seit einigen
wochen sehr klare anleitung oder
empfehlungen gegeben für ärzte wann sie
eine person testen sollen oder nicht
diese diese empfehlungen sind gemündet
ich weiß nicht mehr vor wie viel wochen
in einem fluss schema wo wir kategorien
gebildet haben gesagt haben wenn
menschen aus einem risikogebiet kommen
wenn menschen kontakt hat einen längeren
kontakt zu einem erkrankten mehr als 15
minuten zwei meter abstand so dann
werden die personen kategorisiert das
heißt wir haben den ärzten ganz
systematisch an die hand gegeben wann
macht es sinn jemanden zu testen und
wann macht es keinen sinn
wir haben risikokategorien definiert wir
haben gesagt wenn ein mensch aus einem
risikogebiet zb einreist
aber er hatte dort kein kontakt mit
einem kranken person dann kann er ganz
normal zur arbeit gehen er sollte nur
sich selber 14 tage lang beobachten wenn
er das gefühl hat er wird krank bleibt
er lieber zu hause ruft beim arzt an und
spricht mit ihm
durch diese systematische vorangehen zu
reise und das wird unser ganzes krisen
management nicht nur seit dem 6 januar
seitdem wir über diese dinge nachdenken
sondern auch die ganze zeit ist wir
werden immer ein systematisches
krisen-management haben das hat dazu
geführt dass in deutschland sehr früh
patienten gezielt testungen zugeführt
wurden
und wir fordern natürlich auch auf dass
das so bleibt wir möchten nicht dass
menschen ohne anlass sich einfach testen
lassen und dann die tests kapazitäten
verbrauchen die man für diejenigen lasst
die vielleicht einen höheren anlass
haben getestet zu werden
wir geben den ärzten anweisungen das zu
tun und wir fordern natürlich auch die
bürger und bürgerinnen auf weil unsere
website rein zu schauen um zu sehen
warum wir das tun und ich denke durch
diese strategie haben wir in deutschland
s erreicht dass wir den beginn der
epidemie sehr früh erkannt haben
das ist ein großer vorteil ja denn wenn
jetzt davon gesprochen wird wir haben
erst 1139 fälle oder so diese fälle
gehen nach oben diese fälle werden mehr
es werden mehr fälle kommen es werden
mehr schwere verlauf fälle kommen sind
auch er gestern die ersten beiden
patienten verstorben
und es werden natürlich auch weitere
patienten versterben das heißt aber wir
haben noch die zeit gehabt die
krankenhäuser die landräte die
entscheide sich darauf vorzubereiten die
firmen sich darauf vorzubereiten dass
sie zum beispiel home office machen und
so weiter das heißt also wir sind in der
guten situation dass wir durch diese
systematisch strategische vorgehen
unsere ärzte bewegt haben zu wissen was
sie tun und lassen soll
und das ist ein großer vorteil und
darüber bin ich sehr froh
ja ich bin noch ganz gerne wie gut man
im moment noch in der lage ist in
deutschland die infektionsketten
nachzuvollziehen
ja das ist das hängt von den
einzelfällen also in dem gebiet über das
wir die meiste zeit sprechen das ist der
kreis heinsberg
dort gelingt das momentan nicht ja das
gelingt doch nicht dass das ist das ist
so das ist ja auch der grund warum wir
inzwischen so viele fälle haben
außerhalb heinsbergs also wo die die
infektionsquelle der der der
epidemiologische linke über dessen in
der optisch zusammenhang 1 verlässt und
in den anderen regionen gelingt das aber
noch ja und das ist auch wieder wichtig
zu verstehen
es wird immer so sein dass
unterschiedliche regionen in deutschland
in einem unterschiedlichen status sind
zurzeit ist eben nur heinsberg ein
besonders betroffenes gebiet morgen mag
ist ein anderes gebiet zusätzlich seien
da ist eine dynamik drin die wir auch
nicht vorhersagen aber wir müssen
ständig das ziel haben dass für den
ausbruch die jeweiligen ausbrüche in die
wir haben verlangsamen teilweise stoppen
können es gelingt ja auch weiterhin
ausbrüche zu stoppen
in fact ketten zu durchbrechen wie lange
das immer gelingt und ob das in jedem
fall gelegen
das sei der hergestellt aber wir müssen
es nach wie vor weiter versuchen weil
wir diese ausbreitung verlangsamen
und je nachdem wie gut die kapazitäten
der gesundheitsämter sind je nachdem wie
auch die empfehlung des robert
koch-instituts umgesetzt werden wir
können ja auch teilweise vor ort
unterstützen
aber wir haben bestimmte teams eine
bestimmte anzahl von teams die dann vor
ort unterstützt die die kolleginnen und
kollegen gelingt das mal besser und mal
schlechter und es ist alles eine frage
der zeit wann wir mehr ausbrüche haben
und es eben schlechter gelingt aber
solange wir können werden wir in fact
kehrten nachvollziehen um
kontaktpersonen zu bitten
zu hause zu bleiben noch mal die ganz
einfache logik dahinter ist die eine
person die angesteckt ist steckt andere
menschen an wenn sie zu hause bleiben
kann steckt sie eben nicht so viele an
menschen an eine ganz einfache schlichte
logik die aber von ganz ganz großer
bedeutung ist gibt's weitere fragen von
den hinteren reihen
das ist nicht der fall dann bedanke ich
mich ganz herzlich dass sie da waren und
kurz das kurze sammle statement im foyer
dort geschaffen wir aber wirklich ein
kurzes bitte danke